hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter eight of his work the
categories Aristotle is discussing
quality or poyo taste or to poem in
Greek and he distinguishes between four
different types of qualities the second
type that he talks about is what he
terms natural capacities dunah dunah
mates would be the plural Dunamis
physique a natural capacity that
somebody or something has and he says
that all this applies to all terms that
denote some sort of capacity of Dunamis
in Greek Dunamis means capacity ability
power is another way that we translate
it or an incapacity the opposite of a
capacity and a Dunamis that is from
nature so what he's distinguishing this
from is the type of qualities that he
had just talked about as the first type
that is habits and dispositions and he
says this is not from being disposed in
a certain way yet case they post post
just means in a certain way and D a case
thigh is the word that we're getting D a
thesis problem which means disposition
some of those dispositions would would
be things that are easily changed like
being hot or cold some of them would be
the sorts of things that we developed
through habituation so they would be
habits like those of virtue and vice or
knowledge types of knowledge on the
other hand so we're not talking about
anything like that we're talking about
things that a person or by extension a
thing has by its nature which is
probably going to mean its bodily nature
so a little bit later Aristotle is going
to talk about this as being a capacity
or an incapacity to do something easily
Chronos in Greek is the word for that or
not to suffer something made in poskim
now the reason why I put the Greek terms
here is because when you're looking at
this this work the categories we're
looking right now the category of
quality but there are also later on
not very much discussed in this work but
there are two other categories that are
coming up in this sentence place I you
know is coming from phu yen which is the
category of doing or doing something to
something right so the that category is
already involved here in the capacity to
do something easily and then it's
correlative suffering or passion it's
sometimes translated pas skåne
you know pas faim it's it's really the
same sort of thing these are not you
know like I said all that much discussed
in the categories itself but they are
also ways that things are talked about
so there's a sort of intrusion of
another category into this type of
quality so many of us have some capacity
to do some things more easily than
others by nature for example some people
learn more quickly when it comes to
intellectual things other people are you
know better at physical activities right
some people we could also talk about you
know not to suffer something not to have
to endure something to be able to resist
it right some people have a very
difficult time sitting in the classroom
putting their their rear in a seat and
paying attention to what's on the board
that well that might be something that
Aristotle would call a natural
incapacity right and we can come up with
lots of other examples some people you
know take him into a classroom and you
teach them juggling and they can figure
it out very quickly I never have able to
do that sort of thing but there have
been other things that I found myself
having a natural capacity to do you know
that that other people had a harder time
with and so we all have things along
these lines for example I have a ability
to take a musical instrument and within
a fairly short time figure out the range
of sounds that it can make and how
they're you know structured in relation
to each other that's that's probably
some sort of natural capacity that not
everybody else has I had a friend who
actually had a perfect pitch he could
hear any sound and tell you where it fit
in like he would hear the the balfour
class he'd say that's an e e flat and
it's a little bit sharp if they were
tuning it it would sound a little bit
better he actually could do something
quite impressive he could move a piano
and then retune the piano just by ear on
his own
well that is that's on his part of
natural capacity way beyond the natural
capacity that I have to do something
easily right
you know other cases it might be to
resist something some people like for
example Socrates Socrates was renowned
for his ability
you resist the summer heat and the
winter cold and to never actually get
intoxicated when drinking and we don't
know if that's actually true or not
might have been just a legend but but it
would be an example of what Aristotle is
talking about here so other people have
a natural incapacity when it comes to
alcohol right we call them cheap drunks
because you can just take them and give
them one shot and suddenly they're
intoxicated well that would be an
example of an incapacity to not be able
to resist something right so what are
the examples that Aristotle himself uses
I've given you a number of examples so
far well he talks at first about boxers
and runners this is kind of an
interesting thing so athleticism right
athleticism is in many respects of
natural capacity it can of course be
developed further this is what training
or ask a sis which the Greeks knew a lot
about was important for but some people
just are not going to be good runners
and other people you know even if they
don't have any training they are good
runners that might change over time
right
you could you could actually you know
start out at one point in your life as a
good runner and then maybe by the time
you're in your 40s you're no longer
there's nothing like that likewise he
says other people are good boxers they
have that sort of you know set of my
column impulses or reactions that you
know let them figure out when they
should you know dodge or doc or you know
when one's a good time to throw in the
the punch right these are the sorts of
things that that coaches actually look
for and so you can describe any athlete
you know as having sort of natural
talent in in these respects it's
interesting because and this is a bit of
a side note that Aristotle doesn't
discuss oftentimes when we attribute
something like this to a person we
pigeonhole them and we said okay we
figured out what their natural capacity
is and we don't realize that they have
other capacities so you see for example
you know in the NFL the National
Football League some players that start
out in one position and then they get
moved to a different position these
require extreme amounts of skill that's
been developed on the basis of natural
capacities and then training but they
may have you know been pegged as this
position here right and then somebody
realizes no actually they could be good
for this position here for for example
somebody might be set up to be you know
a tight end and then you know things get
screwed up on the team and suddenly
they're in the running back position and
everyone's like oh this is gonna be
terrible but it turns out that's what
they had the capacity to do similarly we
can we can talk about other things as
well
Aristotle talks also about health and
disease and here he says something quite
interesting so we might think about this
as having a healthy Constitution and a
sickly or diseased Constitution he says
when we speak of the healthy we mean not
just that these people are actually in a
state of health that would be a
different kind of thing we're saying
that such people have powers of
resistance ready
innate constitutional against all the
commoner ills so these are the people
that you know they go to the restaurant
with all their friends and everybody
gets food poisoning but this person it
just gives them a little bit of
indigestion or or they feel a little run
down everybody else is you know laid out
for a day or so all right or you know we
pick other examples the the example of
Socrates would be an extreme example the
example of somebody at the other extreme
would be for example Nietzsche who had a
sickly Constitution and spent a lot of
time in bed in between bouts of writing
and before that teaching so he says when
we speak of the sickly we
in those who seem to possess no such
powers they don't have the capacity to
resist the things that lay other people
down so you know nowadays we might talk
about somebody having a compromised
immune system that would be similar to
what Aristotle is talking about as this
this natural capacity in that case it's
probably unless they were born with it
because something happened over time
like you know toxins and the environment
that they were exposed to or you know
toxins that they themselves ingested you
know like if people indulge themselves
too much in certain substances but that
would that would be an example of what
he's calling natural capacity the third
type that he talks about as an example
doesn't apply to human beings quite so
much although I suppose you could say
hardness and softness works you know
even for human bodies right some
people's bones are harder others are you
know more brittle or not as dense
so hardness and softness he says we
predicate hardness of that which resists
ready disintegration and softness of
that which does not there were thinking
more in terms of something that's just a
capacity of a physical object so you
know we could use for examples the paper
of this book is not as hard as the chalk
of this piece of chalk and this toy I
suppose that you probably would say is
softer in that respect then no the paper
is probably softer it's easier to rip
it's easier to destroy than the tie the
tie is a woven fabric so the time would
be somewhere in between the paper and
the chalk in terms of its natural
capacity to resist dissolution in that
respect so this is the the this sort of
subcategory of natural capacity a type
of quality